the hell is mark murphy doing it is
complete bullcrap obviously they do not
know who they're dealing with aaron
rodgers the type of guy who reads this
and goes this freaking ass beep i bet
you aaron rodgers went out and worked
harder this weekend because he goes man
i can't wait to get to green bay and
just totally ruin mark murphy's life hey
up yours i'm here and i'm better than
ever
up your butt joe boo aaron rodgers is
not number two uh oh i know aaron
rodgers is number three that guy you're
defending you're dropping
although he was wasn't he was number
three last year he's holding steady at
number three he's just been leap frogged
by a much younger and apparently
according to you much not much better
but better enough so anyway roger's at
three
josh allen at two yeah go ahead say it i
think we can figure it out yeah i mean
we can figure it out because we know who
never conversation we know who number
one is that's fine
but roger's three allen two let's focus
on rogers because i recall distinctly
last year when you installed rogers at
three you were concerned that based on
the 2019 film even though the packers
went 13-3 and got to the nfc
championship you saw some signs of
slippage and obviously the packers did
too or they wouldn't have drafted jordan
love they saw something that made them
think it would make sense now
to take a quarterback
what did you see different between
rogers 2019 and 2020
and what about that wasn't enough to
cause him to move higher than number
three well listen it was a phenomenal
year he improved in a lot of ways from
the things that were negative from 2019.
you know honestly i thought he actually
moved around a little bit last year
better compared to 2019 we've talked
about that i think he was a little bit
more muscular and twitchy that way where
in 2019 he got into that yoga tom brady
and it's like no you're not that kind of
athlete or that guy your different body
types everything like that so that was
better but i think more than anything
mike he let it rip a little bit more
last year now i think he could still let
it rip a little bit more to where he can
be a hair careful you know again i i
look at roger sometimes and just go
i mean you're aaron rodgers you could
fit that ball into that window or you
that guy's got him beat by a foot you
should throw it now there was less of
that but that would be a little bit of
the negative but i think that was the
big turnaround from 2019. remember 2019
he had that moment with matt lefleur on
the sideline where they had that
argument early in the year that was what
it was all about he had a wide open in
cut and matt lefor's like you're aaron
rodgers you you hit that bullseye every
time we can't turn that down he turned
less of him down last year that's for
sure i mean he's a zen master he still
is so incredible with his decision
making his throwing is still
the greatest i mean it's still one of
the greatest arms in football right now
in the history of the sport even at his
age at this moment and you could see
here i mean you can still push the ball
down the field with incredible ease but
it rogers is less the magic man that we
see maybe mahomes and josh allen he is
going to do it more with his eyes and
his brain and then his high level
accurate throwing off of that you know
you saw in that clip against
jacksonville i mean he does a great job
of moving the safety and everything like
that they put so much on him you know
throughout the offense and again his
quick release he throws a perfect spiral
i mean these throws right here i mean
come on it's like there's a magnet to
valdez scantling i mean that's that's
how special it is but you see here too
it's a lot more in the pocket you know
than rogers of four and five years ago
but his
recognition of defenses getting the team
in the right play and then of course
i mean almost never misses a throw
almost never
that's where rogers is special and he's
still an incredible incredible
quarterback listen it hurt my soul to
make them number three but for my money
one and two are really freaking awesome
are you kidding me with that throw right
there i mean that's that's amazing
believable it's unbelievable the problem
is the guy the two guys we're going to
talk about before that have like a
million of those type of plays and
that's why they're in front of him but
roger's still amazing and certainly one
of the best quarterbacks in the game
and the reigning mvp and to be the mvp
considering all these other great
quarterbacks that are currently in the
nfl that that is incredible and and it's
what's made the drama even more
compelling you don't see this
from
the reigning mvp everything should be
perfect when you're talking about the
reigning mvp but as aaron rodgers said a
few weeks back playing the way he did
last year threw a wrench messed up made
me believe that
that they were ready after 2020 going
into the season to make the change and
now they can't and now they've
recognized they they have they have
created a monster that is very good for
them on the football field but a
headache for upper management off the
football field yes okay so
here let's go forward yeah
what what can rogers do if anything
this year
to get you to move him higher than three
or is three as high as he's ever gonna
be given all these other great
quarterbacks in the league i think he
could still be
you know
two
you know maybe one you know barring
injury yeah can he move up barring
injury to one of the top guys i think he
could yes i don't know if he can be
number one anymore i i don't know i
don't you know this
mahomes is freaking special i don't know
what else to say it's as awesome as i
think aaron rodgers is and is the
greatest quarterback i've ever seen
especially when he was his prime i mean
mahomes is he's on track to be that guy
too and he hasn't even started the prime
of his career and the problem is the
other guy that's in front of him josh
allen it's the same thing so that's
where it'll be tough but yeah he he's
he's capable of that type of play listen
if some coach in the nfl came to me and
went no you're wrong i think rogers is
one or two i wouldn't go oh you're crazy
that stupid i understand that reasonable
minds might see this differently i get
that um i do but yeah for for you know
rogers has become
less the athletic freak right and a
little bit more of the zen master
unbelievable thrower manipulate you with
eyes and brain and i mean look at this
play this is a great one matt casey
found this this just shows you like
remember this play from the rams game in
the playoffs they're going to send
devonta adams in motion he's checking it
all out because he wants to make sure
he's getting the right coverage for this
tricky little play where they do this
all right so he goes that way evaluates
the coverage okay yep i think i got what
i want that's perfect all right let's
get set up here we go let me make sure
everybody knows exactly what's going on
and
you know again he's going to send
devonta adams back across now in a hurry
because he's going wait i got it
and i think they're going to be confused
here and whatever else and of course
they are and this is where rogers is
special too not only the quickness of
how his brain works but then the
quickness of how his brain can connect
to his right arm i mean there's nobody
maybe dan marino that can get the ball
up and out of their hands quicker there
look at that a blitzing safety off the
edge he got the snap and got the ball
out and really didn't even have to throw
it sidearm or do anything crazy and
still do it you know that's where to me
he's gone next level and that's where
green bay's really put themselves to
your point mike even more in a in a
corner here because yeah he's playing
awesome and they finally have wired the
robot like we talked about with derek
carr and gruden to where he's kind of
mastered the offense and he's they have
a nice combination with what lefleur
does and how rogers works at the line of
scrimmage and that's also will be a
downfall of the football team if they
don't have that aspect of rogers you
know behind center
and i love that clip because
he lulls them to sleep yes as adams is
going right to the left
and
and then it just it's like the play
began before the play began
adam sprints back across he's already
into his route and the ball hasn't been
snapped yet and you see the guy
but jaylen ramsey can't get across the
formation yeah cover him they're
supposed to switch it and all that i
believe that's why jalen ramsey's yells
at the end of the play because they were
supposed to switch where he now gets you
know the stationary guy and that guy
that was outside has to go out to
devonte adams but that's the beauty of
rogers he understood that he knew the
blitz that was coming he knew it all so
once he sent that motion like you said
he gave him the old okie doke it was
like okay now fly across that hut boom
and that's that's where he's amazing an
incredible down the field thrower but
also
an incredible short ball thrower to
where he could throw those bubble
screens or swing passes to aaron jones
out of the backfield and they never
break stride and they're able to
capitalize on all that's there to be
gained after the catch too
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports